hi everyone in this video we'll talk
about vitamin c
and its health benefits so what comes in
your mind when you think about the term
vitamin c
yes i am right you are thinking about
orange
or lemon right exactly now the biggest
question in this covid time is whether
vitamin c
boost your immunity and help you to
fight kovi
this question would be analyzed in this
video so stay tuned
at the end of this video now who don't
like a glass of lemonade or
orange juice in this video we would
analyze the health benefit of
one glass of orange juice which contains
loads and loads of vitamin c
so vitamin c is chemically known as
ascorbic acid and it can be found
in various sources the best source for
vitamin c
is not oranges but bell pepper red bell
pepper
was shown to contain vitamin c five
times more
than oranges other than bell pepper
obviously in lemons oranges guava
brussels sprout cauliflower or in kiwi
we can find
quite a lot of vitamin c
now vitamin c is water soluble and
pretty much heat labile
so it can be degraded if you cook
food that contains vitamin c for example
if you are cooking bell pepper
then and there vitamin c is degraded
so it is always advisable that vitamin
c containing food should be consumed in
a salad format
which keeps the vitamin c in intact and
makes it more available towards our body
now we know that our body is bombarded
with several super oxide ions or
reactive oxygen species which we call
ross every day
this leads to damaging dna and protein
damage in membrane or even increase the
risk of inflammation
ascorbic acid has a negative role
in terms of modulating these
reactive oxygen species it works like a
ros
scavenger now vitamin c is crucial for
wound healing and collagen synthesis
it accelerates the process of wound
healing
and helps in the steps of collagen
biosynthesis
additionally research has shown that
vitamin c
can promote good cardiovascular health
it also reduce the chance of heart
attack
or stroke moreover
vitamin c has a lot of benefit in terms
of skin and hair
since it promotes collagen synthesis it
is beneficial for your
skin but how now collagen
has triple helix structure each of these
collagen helix can get
hydroxylated and that
gives the rigidity towards these
collagen helix
now these hydroxylation process is
augmented by several
hydroxylase enzyme and ascorbic acid or
vitamin c
works like a coenzyme for these enzymes
and that is how it helps to make our
skin
glowy vitamin c
aids in iron uptake in the intestine
and that is why vitamin c reduce the
chances of iron deficiency
moreover we need to understand how
vitamin c affects our brain
it turns out vitamin c is interrelated
with brain function
you know inside our brain the neurons
are connected via
synapses and we can see at the synapses
neurotransmitter
establish the link many neurotransmitter
biogenesis
involves the role of vitamin c for
example when dopamine is converted to
norepinephrine
this hydroxylase pros this hydroxylation
process
is aided by dopamine on oxygenase
and vitamin c plays significant role in
this step
similarly in serotonin biogenesis from
tryptophan to serotonin there is a
hydroxylation process which is aided by
hydroxylase enzyme
and vitamin c plays a role as
a coenzyme now we have
one misconception that ascorbic acid can
really fight
against covid19 virus it's not true
ascorbic acid does not have any kind of
ability to kill the virus
then how vitamin c is beneficial let me
tell you the science behind it
it has been shown that all the
critical covid cases are associated with
low vitamin c levels risk of pneumonia
is significantly high when vitamin c
level was reduced in the patient's body
now post-mortem investigation in kovid19
death shows
that secondary pneumonia phenomena exist
now total pneumonia cohorts comprise 62
percent of hypervitaminosis of
c so all of these evidences
suggest us that reduction in vitamin
c level makes you more susceptible
towards a
critical covid infection
but this does not mean consuming a lots
of orange
you can totally kick out kovid infection
that is
not there is no one-to-one correlation
like that it's a total misconception
now not only vitamin c along with
vitamin c
nice food which are enriched in vitamin
macro and micronutrients along with that
plenty of fluids adequate amount of
sleep
lowered stress level and getting rid of
all the bad habits can overall boost
your immune system
and that would help indirectly to fight
your body
against the virus none of these items or
none of these factors can
individually contribute towards immune
boosting
but overall they can help your
body's immune system to perform better
so moral of the story is adequate level
of vitamin c
in your body reduce the chances of
serious infection in kovid
but still it's a clinical observation
now let me tell you what is the effect
of vitamin c on immune cells
we know neutrophils dendritic cells or
macrophages
are innate immune cells if you don't
know what is inner immunity you can
click on the link in the i button
but these innate immune cells use a
mechanism called oxidative
burst to kill pathogens like bacteria
now oxidative bursts make them more
susceptible towards
ros-mediated damages so it is also
harmful for these immune cells
altogether
but these immune cells intake a lot of
vitamin c via specific transporters and
increased uptake of vitamin c is shown
to
have a protective role
now let's say you have a
injury in your hand or somewhere in your
body
so viruses or bacteria would enter
there your immune cell need to reach
that spot for example this neutrophil
need to make its way out of the blood
vessel
and reach the space of infection
so this kind of chemotaxis process is
aided
by vitamin c it has been seen when
animal subjects are devoid of vitamin c
this chemotaxis process
is severely affected
now other than that inflammatory
processes are mediated by
cytokines vitamin c along with vitamin d
and e
overall reduce pro-inflammatory
cytokines
but increase the anti-inflammatory
cytokines and that is how they maintain
the immune homeostasis
so what we learned so far is vitamin c
indirectly modulate the immune function
but it has
no direct role in terms of killing any
pathogen
the deficiency disease of vitamin c
is known as scurvy which is
characterized by bleeding gum
and pulpish appearance of your gum and
this
possibly happens due to a problem in the
connective tissue probably
collagen levels are low now if it is
untreated there could be many associated
problem
so vitamin c deficiency is pretty common
but it is treatable with adequate amount
of vitamin c or
uptaking some amount of supplement so
the question is how much vitamin c
we should consume daily for adults the
recommended daily amount of vitamin
c is 65 to 90 milligrams with the upper
limit of 2000
mg per day now vitamin c doesn't have
adverse effect if you consume it in a
large proportion
but it might cause some
[Music]
might cause some discomfort in your
gastrointestinal tract
but it's rare and different in different
individual so
you can get all of your daily limit of
vitamin c
from food and these are a few vitamin c
enriched food
or otherwise if these food options are
not available to you
one possibility is vitamin c
supplementation
but a food intake is way better than
taking
supplement as per moral of the story we
have learned
a glass of lemonade or a glass of orange
juice has a lot of health benefits
more than what we think it can reduce
inflammation help
it can help in prevent iron deficiency
it can boost our immunity
it can manage blood pressure decrease
the risk of cardiac health and
many more so we should remember one
thing
we should eat and consume food which are
rich in vitamin c but at the same time
we should cook our food in a way
that should not degrade vitamin c
because it is extremely
heat labile uh vitamin
and we should consume more salads and
raw fruit
so if you like this video give it a
quick thumbs up don't forget to like
share and subscribe you can support my
channel via patreon
and thanks for listening please share
this in your network and do let me know
in the comments how you like my video